now let's jump over to Newsmax where
Grant stitchfield is making the other
case which is if Tyree Nichols had just
complied and done what his killer said
to do he wouldn't have been killed
but here are some of the facts that
people aren't talking about
this all could have been avoided with
one simple move
Tyree Nichols could have complied from
the moment he was pulled out of that car
if you watch this interaction
he never really complies until the very
end
he doesn't comply until the very end
dumb dumb Grant stenchfield says
when was he to comply Grant was it when
they stood him up
and punched him in the face
is it when they had him pinned to the
ground and got running starts to kick
him in the head
is that when he should have complied
Grant stenchfield
foreign
it has been said I didn't originate it
but it's been said that cruelty is the
point for conservative politics in
conservative politics whether it be
owning the libs or whatever cruelty is
the point that's how you get the the the
the passions inflamed in Naga world and
that's exactly what this is it's not
just pathetic excuse making
for uh Jack booted armed agents of the
state who uh summarily executed an
unarmed citizen on the streets on the
Suburban streets of Memphis
it's all
listen if we do not get a handle on the
rhetoric if we do not get a handle on
the other side of the aisle and their
carelessness
and their uh lack of concern for
Humanity we're going to be a more
bifurcated Nation than we have ever been
when it is Sport for them to act as
cruel as possible
there's no conversation to be had
and I'd love to know what you think
about all of this we could mix it up in
the comments
David's got a voicemail line this should
be a conversation that continues uh in
the following weeks
I am Jesse dollar Moore I'd love to have
you subscribe to my YouTube channel if I
am your flavor of political commentator
you can go over and subscribe to the
dollar more daily I have a podcast
called I doubt it podcast or you can
um
follow me on social media
at Dollar Moore on Twitter and Instagram
and Tick Tock thanks a lot